وفي المقابل اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
احباط هجوم بطائرات مسيره فوق مقاطعه
كالوجا واضاف بيان الوزاره ان انظمه
الدفاع الجوي اسقطت سته مسيرات من دون
تسجيل اي اصابات بشريه او اضرار ماديه
نور الدين فقط نتوقف عند مقاله مستشار
القائم باعمال مقاطعه
عن الاستعداد للهجوم وان الجانب الروسي لا
يقوم بهذه الخطوه لان مصلحته الان هي في
تقليص قوه الجانب الاوكراني حدثنا عن
تاثير ذلك على الارض وما تشهده انت من
استعداد
بكل تاكيد هناك استراتيجيه عسكريه هنا
تقوم بها القوات الروسيه هناك النقطه
الاساسيه او الاولى التي تحدث عنها مستشار
حاكم اقليم دنيتك الموالي لروسيا والذي
يتحدث عن مساله استنزاف للقوات الاوكرانيه
حينما تقول روسيا بانه في مجموعه من
المناطق خاصه حينما نتحدث عن الشق الجنوبي
من دنياتك ومواقع الصد الروسيه هنا الحديث
عن محاوله استنزاف القدرات القتاليه
القدرات التسليحيه للقوات الاوكرانيه ربما
هذا قد يمهد الطريق للقوات الروسيه
للقيام بعمليات داخل العمق لكن بكل تاكيد
العمليات لحد الساعه لا تزال على وقع الكر
والفرق بين هذه القوات هناك تفاؤل ربما
هنا ربما قد نلمسه من مستشار حاكم اقليم
بنيات حينما يقول بانه لحد الساعه لم
تتمكن الاسلحه الغربيه التي توصلت بها
اوكرانيا من سد النقص الدفاعي للقوات
وربما هناك استنزاف لهذه القدرات ولهذه
الذخيره اذا حينما نتحدث عن هذا المنطق
نتحدث عن منطق الاستنزاف عن منطق الصد
بالمنطقه الجنوبيه الدفاع قوي للقوات
الروسيه لحد الساعه تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه على المنطقه الجنوبيه
باتولوجيا التقدم مترات باتجاه القوات
الروسيه لحد الساعه هناك حديث ان هناك
مقاومه للقوات الروسيه وهناك محاوله
استهداف لهذه القوه هو ما شاهدناه خلال
اليومين الماضيين حينما غيرت القوات
الروسيه الاستراتيجيتها في الخرصون بحيث
اقدمت على استهداف مجموعه من تجمعات
القوات الاوكرانيه وكذلك مواقع الذخيره
عبر استهداف المسيرات وكذلك الطيران
الحربي لكن بكل تاكيد هذه الاستراتيجيه
هنا قد تختلف نوعا ما عن استراتيجيات
القوات الروسيه باتجاه الشمال والشمال
الغربي لاهميه تلك المنطقه اولا لان تلك
المنطقه توجد على الحدود مع وبالتالي تضع
روسيا بحسبانها ان تكون تلك المنطقه مناطق
تهديد لذلك تعمل بشكل حثيت على اختراق
مواقع من تسميهم بالعدو او القوات
الاوكرانيه في جميع الاتجاهات سواء
في كوبيان وهذا كذلك يمهد الطريق للقوات
الروسيه لاقامه محاوله الالتفاف على على
هذه المنطقه اليوم تحدث عنها كذلك مستسار
رئيس الحاكم اقليم الذي قال بان هناك الان
تطبيق شامل لهذه المنطقه ويبدو ان خطوط
الامداد على الاقل خلال الايام المقبله
ربما قد تشهد السيطره عليها او اغلاقها ما
سيمهد الطريق للقوات الروسيه لاحداث خرق
امني وعسكري في هذه المنطقه التي لا تزال
عصيه على القوات الروسيه عن اقتحامها
اشكرك على هذه المعلومات نور الدين دغير
من دوني